[MUSIC]
Hello, everybody.
It is my great pleasure to
introduce Nick Couldry who
is our visiting researcher.
We're delighted to be able to
have him for another month or
so.
Two months, that's excellent.
And he comes to us from the
London School of Economics and
Political Science.
And did all of the great
work of being a chair of
the Media Communication
department and
now has time to continue his
writing because he is one of
the most prolific
writers in our field.
He's working on book nine or
ten,
I don't even know anymore,
I hate you.
And we're really excited to
have him here, thinking about
just fundamental questions
about the compatibility of big
data collection and
democracy, small topic.
So with that, thank you very
much for joining us, Nick.
>> Okay, thank you, Mary.
It's great to be here,
I'm having a great
time at Microsoft.
I recommend it to anyone
watching this later on
the online version,
it's a good deal.
It's a very good deal.
I'm very happy and
I won't want it to end.
But I'll try and introduce you,
in 30, 35 minutes,
into some of the themes that
I've been working on here.
There'll be themes from a joint
book that I'm writing with
Ulysses for
Stanford University Press.
The provisional title is
The Costs of Connection.
But I'm sure it won't end
up being called that.
And I'm gonna talk about
what I call two problems
that arise in thinking
about the types of social
order we're now living
in the age of big data.
And I use the word problem not
in the sense of something we've
gotta fix right now,
but in the sense of,
like the problem of free
will in philosophy.
Something that we're
gonna be thinking about,
puzzling about, always coming
at from different directions,
probably for generations.
That's the scale of problem
I think we're dealing with
in relation to knowledge and
freedom.
And to get started, I just
want to go back, particularly
maybe you heard my white board
talk about six weeks ago or
you didn't, but anyway, to give
you the starting point of how I
approach social theory at all.
So my broad interest is
the relations between media
in a very broad sense, including
information, data collection,
everything we now compact
into that word media, and
communication generally.
And something we might
still want to call society,
the social.
I put it in scare quotes because
I'm not assuming a neatly
functioning order within
national boundaries,
that's absurd now.
We're not talking about that.
But we are talking about
processes of ordering
something like the social, so
it feels social,
which is called the social.
And we're talking about
the role in that ordering
of media infrastructures in
the broadest possible sense.
And I think that's a issue for
social theory, which is
also an issue for economic
theory, political theory.
We all assume some minimal level
order without which we wouldn't
be able to talk about any of
the things we want to talk about
in doing social science.
And I'm particularly interested
in the consequences for
social order in this broad
sense of the fundamental but
completely banal fact today
which is absolutely astonishing.
Which is the embedding
of computing power and
therefore two way or multi-way
connection that's possible
through computing power,
at every point in space.
And because information is
archived at every point in
space time, creating utterly
new types of feedback loops,
which we have not even
begun to theorize.
That's the problem
I'm interested in.
And at the very least, that sort
of deep embedding of computer
power, parallelizations if you
like, creates new forms of
dependence on computing systems,
obviously, which are the basis
of business models, new forms
of social interdependence.
And, since no interdependence
comes without tensions,
social tensions, which we need
to seriously think about.
And if you like, also,
a new type of social complexity.
How can we think about this
multi-dimensional order that
has to be arising somehow in
the middle of all this change?
That's the thing
I'm interested in.
And I just want to introduce
from my previous book,
The Mediated Construction
of Reality,
one concept that I
think is useful.
I won't refer back to
it in detail later on,
but it will give you a flavor of
how I think about this sort of
complexity.
And I talked about it briefly
in the white board talk and
that's a concept from
the German theorist
often neglected now in Britain
and the states, Norbert Elias.
He was a refugee from
Nazi Germany and
lived a lot of his
life in Britain.
He developed a concept to social
complexity which he called
figurations.
And figurations is interesting
because it's very different from
the concept we tend to rely on
to understand complexity today,
which is networks.
Everyone understands a network.
Sets of nodes, physical links or
informational links, which
create a more complex network
space, maybe extremely complex.
Now Elias was also
interested in networks, but
he added a crucial ingredient
which is that they were dynamic,
that they were lattice
works of tensions.
In other words, at each point
in space is an entity that's
pulling the entity at the other
end of that line in the network.
They're dynamic and they're
dynamic because there's meaning
and content, there's something
at stake in the network.
That creates a totally different
type of dynamic tension
from the one we can theorize
the notion of networks.
Which is apparently our
most advanced concept for
complexity but
I think barely even gets going
in thinking about complexity.
He said the behavior of so many
separate people intermeshes,
it's like a fence,
a wire fence pulling to create
the strength of the fence to
form into woven structures.
I just want to illustrate
that in a diagram.
So here's from our book,
you can see that's much
more than a network,
of course, because each entity
is pulling on the other.
It's not just linked,
it's pulling.
And of course each
person in the grouping,
it could be a game of cards,
a game of football,
it could be a corporation,
is being themselves pulled in
multiple directions by
other spaces in society.
So in other words, already,
even in this simple concept, and
that's our version of Elias'
diagram from the early 1970s.
That's how advanced he was in
his thinking about complexity.
Already that implies
a multidimensional order.
A tention in higher dimensions,
which results from this
apparently one dimensional,
two dimensional plane,
which is interesting.
Just to go back a second.
The question then is taking his
concept from the late 70s and
actually he already had
the ideas in the early 30s,
which makes it even
more astonishing.
How can we think about social
order in higher dimensions,
really higher dimensions,
when we take account of all
the institutions in society?
What we call in that previous
book figurations of figurations.
Well here's a diagram of
how that would look like.
So you have the initial
figuration,
which already implies
higher dimensions.
But it itself,
the overall push or tension or
weight if you like at that
figuration is itself being
pulled by other
institutional forces.
So if we think about
Facebook as an institution,
the figuration of figurations.
The group of people who
are designing policy in Facebook
are human beings
like the rest of us,
doing the best to solve
whatever they have to solve and
they have their own
personal histories.
But they're, of course, being
pulled by the economic forces,
which are the basis of the
business model, which in turn,
is being pulled.
By the brand and all the social
tensions that it creates to
represent Facebook
in certain ways.
Which is turn is being pulled
by government, law and so
on, not at infinitum but
on many, many dimensions.
We're looking at hundreds of
dimensions, pooling together,
creating an extremely
complex type of order.
So Let's take, put that
in the background, and now think
about two particular problems.
But before I get
onto my problems,
there's just one more
bit of introduction.
We like to think, of course,
particularly in media studies,
which sometimes presents itself
as study, what's right now?
What's absolutely new?
We like to think that no one
has ever thought about these
problems before, but,
of course, that's not true.
The whole history of social
theory has been puzzling in
different moments of trying to
what the hell is going on here?
We don't have the concepts for
this,
this is what generated
sociology in the first place.
It's what generated the crisis
in sociology in the 60s, and
so on and so forth.
So, can we find any
parallels for the sorts of
radical transformations
we're seeing today?
Well we can.
It's a great book from
the 80s James Beniger,
The Control Revolution which you
may not know if communication is
strongly recommended because
it's one of the very few books
that starts out form
the basis that communication
that's the little area we
look at through the lens and
media studies is actually
the site where all sort of other
forces are being pulled.
They happen to generate things
like the telegraph system,
newspapers.
But that's because of all
these intercepting forces
that operate through them,
that make them necessary,
that sustain them, that
generate crisis through them.
So he sees communications at
the site of an intersection of
massive rep social.
And economic change crossing
areas such as transport,
spacial organization, business.
To give you the simple
example from his book,
which everyone quotes
because it's so vivid.
He explained that at a certain
point it was important to
send the news down the railway
line that the train was coming.
Because there only was one line.
And what if a train was
coming the other way?
There are many accidents
when the ability to send
the message down the line and
to do it in an ordered precise
way that was effective had not
yet been planned and developed.
That's a very simple way
of how new transport
possibilities require
absolutely new communication
in effective structures which
itself links into economics,
business, and so on.
So that's interesting.
So can we think about
today's problems is also
what Beniger called
problems of control.
And just to throw in
one other example,
because it's an illustration
of sort of great conversations
I'm having here in Microsoft.
Tomorrow in our reading group
on radical social theory
we're discussing another great
historical parallel which will
be work, he has the great
transformation which
was on the emergence of markets
in the early 19th century,
in the industrial capitalism and
how that didn't just happen
because markets were somehow
natural and just waiting to
be pulled out of the box.
The sorts of assumptions that
make a market possible, if I do
that, you, of course, are gonna
do that in return have to be
socially constructed, they have
to be built and much of that
building was very painful and
very difficult because it went
against previous assumptions
the way the economy worked.
So, another example.
But taking those two together,
both of them bring out for
me that even if your
interest is economics or
let's say government how
the socialist constructed.
How it comes to be
socially possible
that human entities could
be doing other things,
interact that way is
enormously important.
So I will want to argue that
social theory, whether it's done
well or badly is potentially
very important contribution to
economic theory, political
theory and government and so.
So that's what I'm
gonna think about.
So I'm gonna move on now to the,
what they're calling the
knowledge problem in the age of
big data I don't need to say
anymore about what big data is.
It's in the popular discourse,
and
many of us in this room
are experts in what it means in
terms of the practices of
collecting and processing data.
And beyond that,
the stories we're telling
ourselves about the new types of
knowledge we're getting of
the social through big data.
There's a lot of myth making
about what big data is
doing to the social.
Well there's a lot of serious
thinking about what big data
could do to genuinely
transform our knowledge of
the social world.
All that on top of
the practices themselves.
So let's think
about this problem.
What do I mean by the social?
I'm always asked this so I get
this on the table right away.
The social is not something I
can not neatly define because it
can not be neatly defined.
But it's the word we use to
point at that massive domain of
human activity which is based
in interactions and connections,
without which we can't have
anything like human life.
We can't have a few people
existing in some way for
a few hours or
months in the desert and
dying, utterly
wretched nonsense.
That's why anything recognizable
as successful human life
requires interaction,
connection.
And that's what we're pointing
to when you use the word social.
There is no better definition,
then.
I got that from William Sewell,
the Chicago social theorist.
But that's just the start of
a few interesting questions when
we think about this
knowledge problem.
Because social knowledge isn't
just our knowledge of each other
as individuals.
That's essential but
it's the stories we tell
about the social overall.
Because they're part of how
we situate each of our lives.
So we already get into
a higher order problem,
what is social knowledge.
There's a metaproblem,
in other words,
of how the social world
knows itself at all.
But not just in it.
We have accounts of it.
On the basis which we
say you can't do that.
That's unacceptable or
things can't work that way.
I have a right therefore
to challenge that.
So, social knowledge exists
in various dimensions and
there's always
a neglected level as well,
which Pierre Bourdieu was one of
the first people to point out.
The book in the 70s
we forget that
social science
itself is knowledge.
Like all knowledge
has to be produced.
Humans have to be in
institutions very often.
They have to travel
to the right place.
They need tools and so on.
There's always the hidden
social conditions of producing
what we know about
the social and
we need a sociology to
understand that too.
So there's many dimensions to
how we come to know the social
at all, and those dimensions
are now changing.
And there's a tendency,
always which
pointed out to ignore those
underlying conditions,
which say what can be
knowledge of the social.
We assume we just know,
we just see right in there.
But that possibility seeing
right into things is it so
socially produced into
various forms of expertise,
privilege, institutional
resource.
And so on, which are really
important, especially
when an ability to see things
is changing, as it is right now.
And we can also think about
how the knowledge of those
conditions under which social
knowledge is produced,
is it's deliberately
made opaque, very often.
We don't always want people
to see into the engine room,
to see how we claim
to see the world.
Cuz that would
lead to challenge.
And I think we're in a stage
where the certain things
are very opaque about
the new types of knowledge.
So I wanted to come on to that.
Now, this is where I think
historical comparison
becomes really useful because,
I've been working on this
a lot while I've been here.
Because if we just started
from what we have now,
it's bewildering very fast
changing and therefore,
the natural thing is to say,
well let's go with those who
are doing the work, and
follow what they say.
But then we have no
historical comparison at all.
We have no sense of whether
previous societies have gone
through similar things.
And if they have, did it work
out radically different way?
And that's why I want
to suggest to you for
a few minutes that
the comparison with the 19th
century to early 20th century
leaves us some very surprising
differences from
where we are today.
I won't go into the detail
of the history statistics,
it's not my expertise,
but I'm rereading a lot of the
books by those who are experts.
And it throws up some very
interesting differences.
So in the early 19th century,
late 18th century,
there was a radical shift in
the knowledge of the social,
particularly in Europe and
North America.
So the world shifted from one
in which there was human nature,
which was largely fixed, and
written about from Aristotle.
And there was human variation.
Individuals were of
course slightly variable.
But we didn't know much
about that and therefore,
it wasn't very interesting and
nothing ordered or
structured could be said about
it, that was all there was.
So there wasn't really much of
a development of social science.
Statistics based on counting,
gathering data counting starting
to reserve numerical and
statistical patterns,
radically change what could
be said about the social.
And many would argue actually
created the possibility of
a social, of the idea there was
something ordered out there
which was the social.
And this was
a complex social and
of course highly
political process.
As Ted Porter, one of the
leading historians of numbers
statistics writes,
the credibility
of numbers doesn't just exist,
it's a social and moral problem.
People fight over which
numbers are better.
Who has the right to
generate numbers and
apply them to the world?
Power must be exercised in
a variety of ways to make
the measurements and
tallies valid.
Well, I think it's pretty
obvious we're in a such a moment
of history right now.
There's a massive battle going
on about the measurements and
the tallies.
And he also says that when
a power game is won and
certain measurements and
tallies become normative, they
are very effective in changing
the world in certain ways.
Or as Ian Hacking puts it
in another great book,
ways of making up people.
Making people who can now be
talked about in new ways.
And without going into any
details, those of you in
economics will obviously know
the history was the emergence of
extraordinary new ideas of
the average, the normal person
around which statistical
variation always tended to vary.
This was an extraordinary
concept, the statistical norm.
And that was based in
very material tools,
putting data together in
packages that could be
then talked about as one thing.
The idea of the map which
had data encoded into it.
A great example,
because I see if I walk around
the Geography Department at LSC,
they still have it on the walls.
It's Charles Booth's Map
of London Poverty,
based on his discovery
of eight dimensions of
poverty which came out
of statistical analysis.
And, it was put up on the wall
in all sorts of institutes.
So we can think about
how London is organized.
Some interesting
history by Dan Balcer.
Historian in the insurance
industry on,
which very is parallel to what
we're going through today,
the emergence of new
data aggregates.
So that's,
if you like in Snapshoddy, what
Anne Desrosieres, another writer
about statistics calls the
concrete history of abstraction.
Abstraction doesn't
just come from nowhere,
it has to be built in
particular resources.
It's hard to speak
abstractly and
get it to stick on the world.
So what are the parallels today?
Well, let's just sum up what
my argument's gonna be and
I'll go through some
more detail in a moment.
I think today's massive
explosion of social knowledge
for big data has two very
distinctive features compared
with the 19th century.
The first is the depth.
Almost infinite depth and
the absolute continuity of
which data i's collected.
This is no parallel
in the 19th century.
There were censuses
every ten years.
There were various other tools
to gather data where you could
put it together somehow.
There was nothing remotely
similar to the depth and
continuity we now take for
granted.
And secondly,
who's gathering the data?
Who controls the data?
On what terms?
As we'll see, it's very
different today from the way
it was in the 19th century.
So just going a bit more detail.
The point about continuity,
as I said,
data in the 19th century
was gathered episodically.
Therefore, there was
no n equals all,
n equals all was unimaginable.
There was,
n was relatively small and
might include the whole country
if you could compel people to
fill in the census, but
that was only every ten years.
And the gap in between
was not known.
Insurance companies tried
to do better than that, but
there were limits to
what they could do.
The key point through I think is
that social knowledge today is
increasingly generated
by private capacities.
I call them capacities cuz
it's not just corporations.
Any business that starts up
today almost certainly has in
its business model, creating
a platform with apps linked to
apps and APIs to gather data.
Either for it's own purposes or
to sell that data on or
to somehow make itself
valuable to other corporations
because it has that data.
So the collection of
data is built in to
almost any business model today,
any private business model.
States and
publics are also involved, but
most of the data is privately
gathered and that's important.
It's also important that this,
I mean,
we're not just talking about
capacities, we're talking about
the values which govern
the collection of data.
I was struck in
Ted Porter's book,
he discusses a debate in
the 19th century in France.
Where there was this statistical
association of France which said
the reason we need statistics
is to defend public value
against private values.
If we get a picture
of the whole,
which we can through statistics,
then we can answer the private
interests who want to dominate
society one way or the other.
I think it's obvious that
that is radically different
from the official goals of
collection of the data today.
Although there are exceptions
which I'll come back to.
Another key point is the opacity
of gathering knowledge today.
This I'm sure there are many
things which remain obscure to
people about the statistics in
the 19th century obviously.
But in broad terms, these were
information that was gathered
publicly through public means
and was able open public debate.
So insurers had a few means on
the basis of which they wrote
the premiums for people
wanting insurance policies.
And when it became obviously
known that they gave
different premiums to black
people versus white people,
it wasn't a very difficult
inference to say that race had
something to do with it.
And there were fierce contests
in the United States about that.
There were not so
many variables involved.
Today, there are disputes
about this things.
But as we know it's not so
easy to challenge.
Why in a particular way
an algorithm has presented this
in your news feed today and
presented that in your
news feed yesterday.
And.
Also this lead to very
interesting new debates about
things which were
inherently public.
What is poverty?
That was a notion that emerged
after gathering various
statistical information,
aggregating it to talk
about a new thing, poverty,
as something which is socially
determined, socially shaped.
Not just down to fate,
not just curable by charity.
Something that could
socially be attacked
because it was understood
statistically.
And that produced public debates
about the outputs of data which
is very different, I think,
from what Frank Pasquale,
in his recent book, talks of
is the generation of data
behind us or the one we mirror.
I talked about Booth's
poverty map before.
And, of course, we know that,
although, in the past, too,
data was used to discriminate
against people of course.
There was also,
the main emphasis was on
social generalizations,
trying to understand society
itself, that goes on today.
But, as we know, the principle
purpose of data collection today
is to make differentiations,
as data always does.
And to do it to change the
actions which corporations can
take, which is to discriminate,
discriminating particularities.
It's true that some of the
people in the marketing industry
and the data industry will
tell you something different.
That's a quote from a recent
book on the marketing industry.
But the truth very soon will
be present in everything.
If we're all wearing devices
which are measuring everything
about us,
communicating with other things.
The truth will be right there,
easily accessible.
You'll know everything
about yourself and
your loved ones if you opt in.
Actually, I think that's
a very misleading view about
the development.
Actually we're talking
about much more particular
stories today.
And I think it's interesting,
again,
we go back to
the public-private thing.
If you know anything about
19th century and statistics,
one of the key debates at that
time, in the public realm,
it even reached
Charles Dickens' novel,
Hard Times,
was the question of freedom.
If it was true there
was an average man,
as they called it, a statistical
norm, where was free will?
Some people argued that
there was no free will.
That we were condemned just to
play out the average just in our
particular bodies.
Others argue fiercely that
the individual remained free, we
were just talking a statistical
pattern at the general level.
This was one of the biggest
debates about statistics,
which were about one of the most
fundamental questions in
philosophy, free will.
I don't yet see debates about
the significance of big data
on that philosophical and
normative level.
But those were normal
in the 19th century,
and that's an interesting
difference.
But it leads to another
point about what I
call conditionality.
Of course,
the state could compel you to
answer the census in a way.
In a sense, we're compelled to
give in certain information when
we wanna join a platform.
But I think that
conditionality was different.
As I said this was
much less frequent,
the data, the gathering of data.
And also, it's now part of
an individual deal we all do.
To get access to a platform,
type of information,
we just have to give a certain
amount of information.
And we consent to certain
terms and conditions.
It's almost a very pervasive
conditionality that's extremely
hard to opt out of.
And it has consequences for
right across our lives in a way
that the gathering of data by
the 19th century state did not.
Because the state
was much weaker.
That's the general comparison,
let's just move on to the sort
of questions that emergent,
what I'm calling the problem
of knowledge today.
The first sort of other thing
is, which I can't answer,
of course, because no one can
yet, is what sort of social
will this new model of
social knowledge production?
What sort of social will
it produce in the long run?
Will there be a parallel to what
we had in the 19th century that
will invent a totally new
concept like poverty?
To radically see into
the social world,
change the politics
of the social.
Well, with so many sources of
knowledge in private hands I'm
not seeing many
signs of that yet.
It is a valid question,
we don't know what sort of
social will be generated.
But we can be sure
a different social
will be generated from this very
new type of social knowledge.
That raises questions of
legitimacy, which are, again,
unfathomable.
No social knowledge
can be generated and
be effective unless
people trust it.
And people trust and respect
the authority of those gathering
the data to do so and the way
they use categorizations.
There are a lot of disputes
about the way certain algorithms
work right now,
particularly in US politics.
We don't know
the consequences of those for
the legitimacy of algorithmic
knowledge, generally.
But it's a serious question we
have to think about if we think
about all of this from
a social point of view.
Third question is, is this
really social knowledge at all?
Something that strikes me, I'm
officially a social theorist,
whatever that is.
But then, I often think, well,
Mark Zuckerberg is the highest
paid social theorist
in the world.
And I'm never gonna get
close to his rewards.
Because the branding
of Facebook is based
around social
theoretical claims.
There's a whole website
where Zuckerberg's
very interesting and,
in many ways, impressive or rich
comments on what Facebook is
trying to do, is gathered there.
And here's one particular
one where he said that,
I think it was around 2010, when
they were developing the social
graph and developing
that to a higher level.
He said we believe that
eventually almost all apps you
use are gonna be social.
But in the world,
that's the social world,
I guess, there's a natural
spectrum from behaviors of
the really naturally social
to ones that aren't.
And the ones that are naturally
social are gonna be the ones
that turn to social apps.
So if there's an app for it,
then it's naturally social.
But he's also saying
we're engineering this,
otherwise it wouldn't happen.
So you see there's a very
strange sort of bifurcated
reasoning here,
which is necessary for
the brand that has to
talk about the social.
I'm gonna rush a bit here,
cuz I want to go on
to another problem.
There are some ethical
problems here.
A lot of data is used
to modulate behavior.
There are some signs now
developing, there was
a big Guardian article recently,
about those within the data
industry who are becoming
a little worried about this.
You may have heard of B.J. Fogg,
the Stanford data scientist.
His science of captology,
which is gathering data at
the micro level about people in
order to seriously
influence their behavior.
To nudge them regularly,
so much so
that they never
forget the nudge.
And they, like a ball
in a pinball machine,
will regularly
achieve certain ends.
But Justin Harris,
who worked with him, originally,
raises this question
in a magazine that's
published by the Economist.
What responsibility comes
with the ability to influence
the psychology of
a billion people?
Where's the hippocratic oath?
I mean, do we have an ethics of
this influence on this scale?
Which raises another issue about
the ethics of the gathering of
the data.
Should there be apps for
everything?
The principal of in
equals all of big data,
that you must have as much data
as possible on every conceivable
dimension to bring it together
to allow the computing to take
place hits against basic
ethical questions.
Should we have an app for
whether I'm truly grieving my
mother, or whether I'm really
in love with this person.
Are we already stepping into
territory which is beyond
unacceptable?
And if so, why?
Why is that unacceptable?
Are we clear about why?
Well, are there
questions of intimacy
which we would not allow
data collection to get into?
We don't know
the answer to this.
So I'm just raising
these as questions.
And this takes me to the second
big problem, which I will try
and deal with in five minutes,
to allow for further questions.
Which is the problem of freedom?
Obviously, big data depends on
continuous tracking of people.
I don't need to
elaborate that point.
Kevin Kelly, the West Coast
Tech Evangelist, says in his
new book, The Inevitable, that
tracking is just one of those 12
dimensions of everything
that is now inevitable and
will constitute the new world.
I think there's a problem with
this because what he never talks
about is that tracking is not
just a technical possibility.
It's a social process.
As all social knowledge
production is social.
The Economist,
World Economic Forum and
others talk about social data.
All data, big data.
It's just oil, as exhaust,
it's just there.
But there's no thing
that is just there.
Even physical nature has
to be constructed and
configured in a way so
that we can get value out of it.
And the same is
true of human life.
We have to be configured in
such a way that we can be
in generative data relations
with infrastructures.
So there was no data
that is just there.
And that means there has to be
a social dimension which is
totally absent in
Kevin Kelly's vision, and
it has been since the beginning.
That's from his
famous New Rules for
the New Economy article in 1997.
Where he described the net as
just a collective interaction,
spun off of
a trillion objects and
living beings linked together
through air and glass.
I think that's still
his view today,
and the social just isn't even
in there, in the framing.
And that's a big problem.
The logic of N=all,
which is the big data logic,
therefore has social and ethical
costs, which in principle,
it cannot recognize.
So we have to be able to frame
the problem in other ways, too.
Which is not to not respect
the mathematics and
other skills that go
into generating the data,
because they're
extremely important.
What could we do about this?
There's a lot of debate about
outlawing bad data uses.
And that's relatively
straightforward.
In principle,
except that one of the solutions
is often transparency.
And as Helen Nissenbaum point
out, machine learning is so
complex that there's a limit
to what we can see in order
to be able to see into
machine learning.
We can't fully see into it
because it is a non-linear
process which feed backs on
itself in ways that cannot be
predicted and
can't be seen into.
So there may be problems there.
But they're not what
I wanna focus on.
Some people talk about the
effects of continuous tracking
of people, making them feel
lacking anxious, lacking in
confidence, just in East Germany
before 1989, the life of others.
Well, that's a serious
worry as well.
And there are power
relations there, but
I do think it's
the fundamental worry.
And this is what I
want to focus on.
For me, the fundamental issues,
and it's the one least talked
about right now, is the very
fact of gathering data itself.
That's not to say that all
data gathering is bad.
Of course, I'm not saying that.
But what we're dealing with
is moving to a social order
which is based primarily
on the continuous gathering
of data from individuals.
And the question is,
is this fully compatible with
what we think are our values or
is there a deep tench that
we have to take seriously?
And I think there is a tench.
Let me immediately say, there's
some type of data collection
that we might
generally want to have.
Even on that vast scale.
In the health area, many people
argue that we simply have to
start gathering our health data
to deal with serious disease.
And I take those arguments
really seriously.
Other people argue that it's
better to know how one's body is
functioning on a micro level,
and
it's good to have wearables and
so on and so forth.
I don't dispute that.
The question is, what happens
when this becomes the norm?
And when it even
becomes the requirement
of insurance companies,
employers, friends, and so on.
That's a very different social
order from where I just choose
to understand my body better
as I try to run faster.
That's a radically
different possibility.
Even in the health case and
voluntary self-tracking,
there are major issues
about anonymization.
The data are formally
anonymized.
But there's a lot of debate in
the health literature as whether
anonymization is
actually possible.
So even here,
even in these special cases,
there are worries
about data collection.
There are even fundamental
issues about whether certain
data must always be under
the control of the individual.
The philosopher Daniel Sulmasy
argues that the person's genome
is so fundamental to who they
are and who or what they can be,
that it must only be under
the control of the individual.
Licensable if you like,
to the wider realm.
The dangers are so great of
allowing it to be in control
anything other than that
specific individual.
That's an interesting question.
That's a sort of fundamental,
if you like, to data collection,
and data circulation,
which you might think about.
So starting to wrap up.
There were clearly ethical
tensions, political tensions,
developing here.
For me, the real contradiction
is between the shift to
an order based around
continuous tracking,
which is where we
seem to be going.
And the notion of freedom or
autonomy, which we normally
think is at the basis of
why we are democracies.
Why we pride ourselves
on being free societies.
Why we would even
want democracy.
Without going into any detail,
for me, and I've looked for
a long time, the only
philosophical reference point I
found that helps me at all
here,tTo get right to the core
is Hegel's notion of,
he called it freedom, but
it's really autonomy
that we would say now.
Which he defined this way,
very interestingly.
Freedom is the ability to be
with oneself in the other.
It took me six months
to understand that.
So let me give you a shortcut.
He gets absolutely, in the
beginning of the 19th century,
that identity is relational.
Freedom is relational.
It emerges in social elections.
There's a material
infrastructure.
That could include
some data collection.
That's in the other.
But that necessity to be with
one's self, to have the ability
to reflect continuously in one's
life about where one is going,
what one's done wrong,
what one's life means,
in dialogue continuously
with others.
But always,
it being one's own reflection.
No other entity listening
in at every point or
directing that reflection.
That, for him, is the core
of what human beings are.
That is the eaftos, the self,
eaftos the Greek word.
That is the thing whose
freedom we're talking about.
So what we're talking about
here is not a danger for
a certain capacity or
a dimension,
we're talking about the very
possibility of being a self.
And that, for me, is what's
at stake if we go without any
qualification or debate down
the path of continuous tracking.
And that's why I'm
worried about it.
There's biology here.
Even not very complex animals,
worms and so on,
need a certain space
which they defend.
European data law is very
much related to this.
Julie Cohen has
written about this.
I won't allow time for
questions, I'll just leave that
question hanging and
say well I've done so far.
I think we've reached
the point where we have big
problems about the production
social knowledge and
the condition of
that production.
Which creates tension with core
values, such as freedom and
autonomy, which we simply
have to start debating.
And that means thinking about
all of this as a social process,
which we are involved
in as social beings.
We have a voice in this.
It is really
important therefore,
that we bring together those
that produce social knowledge
validly, smartly, importantly.
We've those, any of us, it could
include all of us in this room
and anyone who's interested
in what the cost of that.
The externalities if you like,
might be when transposed to
the full social scale and
accumulated over time,
over decades.
That's the issue, and I think
we need to be debating it.
Ways forward,
the law is obviously
one very important way.
The European general data
protection regulations is very
interesting because it actually
starts from human rights.
But there's Kate Crawford and
colleagues writing out of
Microsoft New York lab made
a very interesting point.
You can have the best legal
framework you want, but
if it operates in a field of
force where an insurer or
employer requires you to sign
away your data, for a perfectly
valid conditions of running
their employment, or selling
you an insurance policy, that
regulation will not help you.
It's not designed to help you.
It's not designed to
interrupt business,
it's designed to
induce certain checks.
But if the whole push is to
quasi-enforce the giving up of
data, then it won't help us.
So we have to think
about other things.
In the Health Sector,
Barbara Evans,
one of the most brilliant legal
theorists in the health sector
talks about getting together.
This relates to work,
seriously having a collective
conversation about the different
data collection infrastructure
that would help us
bring the problems to the
program, to talk about them, and
try to find collective solutions
to deal with these words.
I think that's a really
interesting example
from the health sector.
But she doesn't come
up with solutions,
she just proposes
the possibility, it's not easy.
And finally, I think, and I draw
this partly from Julie Cummings
work, we do have to, without in
anyway challenging the validity
of collecting data and using
it to provide smart solutions.
We have to raise the
philosophical question, as I've
said before, that the principle
of any which is valid and
interesting mathematically,
must at some point cut across
our ethical limits and say no,
you will not have that data,
you must not collect that data.
Because if you collect that,
you damage the integrity of
what I am, and what you are.
And that's why I think it's
an interesting problem,
that we've just got to
think about a lot more.
So thank you for listening.
Sorry, I waxed went on
slightly beyond my time.
But I hope we have time for
questions, and
don't have to finish
exactly at five.
That's that.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In case you wanted to go
back to a slide.
>> So we actually have ten more
minutes for questions, but
of course we will take your
questions as you give it to us.
>> Sorry, I have so much to say.
>> But
I will let you [INAUDIBLE]
>> Cool. Okay.
>> So a lot of your discussion
made me think of FA Hyatt's
sort of discussion of
the problems of statistics.
So he has this vision in which
the problem with statistics
would be attempt to
essentially organize
an economy using statistics.
Is it statistics or
these aggregate course
things that don't pick
up the particularity of-
>> Yeah.
>> Individual situations and
that the beauty of
the market allegedly.
It's that it delegates to
quote the man on the spot
who has this much
more granular data.
It seems like if you substitute
the word market there for
sort of the autonomous free
society, or something like that.
Then, the idea is that once you
start getting that granularity
collected in this automated way,
either individual
cells get delocalized.
They have some identity that
is not related to their
local surroundings and that the
role that plays in society, or
they sort of disappear entirely.
Which was sort of what you
were pointing towards.
So I sort of, maybe that's
not even really a question.
But it's just an interesting
[CROSSTALK] reflection.
>> Well, I think it is
interesting, because it, first
of all, because it zeroes in on
the fundamental question here,
which is about, what is it
to know the social world?
And that was one of the things
that drove his work,
the puzzles about, obviously
that's extremely interesting.
And clearly,
I'm not suggesting for
one moment that somehow
statistics are for
better knowledge of the social,
compared to what we have today.
I'm just looking at
the social externalities,
the costs of this model and
that's where my focus is.
There are many arguments to
say that we will understand
if we go down entirely this way,
many aspects of the social
better than before.
And that's what psychology is
being driven by today and so on.
That incidentally is why I
find those that work for
example with BJ Fog at
Stanford who have been through
the very smartest learning of
what you can do with analytics,
to predict behavior with
extraordinary precision.
Are still are the ones
particularly troubled
by where this is leading.
That's already puts
one to decide there
is more to debate here.
But as to question of the future
itself, well, of course,
that's a great point.
I have no idea where
this is heading.
I think Kevin Carey
implies in his writing
that we should slope
off this rather 18th,
19th century sense of our
particular individualities
came out of a certain phase
of the enlightenment.
Possessive individualism and
so on, and so forth.
And move to a different phase.
Jeremy Rifkin, Wharton Business,
who has made a similar argument
in his zero cost some society,
whatever the title
of his book is.
There's a privacy literally
in it, 18th century notion,
we should just get over it.
But this, of course,
ignores the deep,
almost acultural core
of privacy to notion.
Culture varies, and privacy
varies continuously, of course.
So does autonomy, our sense of
what it is to be autonomous.
But as I said, you only have
to go to relatively simple or
complex animals.
And they,
unless they are swarm animals,
which is a different case,
will defend a space around
the self from where
the environment begins.
That is the space
of that entity.
We're talking, if you like,
about, I think,
that at the core rule of
the discussions of privacy,
autonomy, with all
the confusions and
messiness which is a problem.
There's a certain minimal notion
of the integrity of the self
which I would defy anyone to
say we can dispense with and
still be a self.
It's true we can move into
a collective being, but
I have yet to meet anyone
who actually wants
that when we think
about the costs.
We could have the debate and
there's a sense that
one can't debate it.
It will be a fundamental
phase shift in humanity, but
I don't think we're at least
ready to get there yet
even if we tell ourselves.
Yes, good to see you.
>> Listening to you,
it's a very dystopian view
of the history where
humans created business.
At first they were
bakeries of little mom and
pop businesses and they served
us, and they grew, and they
grew, and then they turned into
contemporary corporations and
what we're seeing is some of the
takeover of human autonomy by
the world of business.
It feels like fundamentally,
it's not simply an issue around
surveillance, per se, but that
this is, when you talk about
it being private entities as
opposed to the government,
that somebody's ostensibly doing
it For the public that these
are these private entities that
society has given birth too.
>> Yeah.
>> That are turning
on the people and
sort of devouring humans.
>> That's not what I
was saying at all.
>> No, no, but it's a feeling
that comes out a little bit.
And that's-
>> I'm happy to respond.
>> And it's the model and
prevalence of the private and
when you talk about
the way forward.
I think an interesting way of
thinking about it is to look at
what are some of the big
problems we want solved?
>> Yeah.
>> So an obvious one
you mentioned was health,
which says, well,
maybe if insurance agencies
are collecting all of this data,
they have to use that data for
health.
And to look [INAUDIBLE]
both had issues around
what is it that we want to see.
And into these increasingly
opaque entities and
institutions, because very
little of this is about turning
the observing eye
into other things.
So if you, for instance,
think about the environment or
think about how different.
The unforeseen consequences
of the way that
money that is given to support
certain types of farms has ended
up having causing
consequences we don't want.
So how do we use this type
of data to better understand
these institutions
[INAUDIBLE] extremely opaque.
And focus on the kind of big
challenges that may involve
data but
it's not necessarily data about.
>> Well, I mean I'm glad you
asked that because of course
I tried to make it clear.
But I'm not against
data collection,
I'm not against data processing.
I said it a few times,
that's not a problem.
It's a new capacity that we have
that we need to nurture and
think about.
What I'm raising is a question,
which is that if I'm right or
even half right, that there's a
difference in the overall social
deal, if you like.
Through which knowledge of
the world is now being generated
compared with a valid comparison
of the 19th and 20th century,
which is simply about
a question of where it goes on.
The sorts of purposes for
which [INAUDIBLE] control and
how far those hopefully open for
debate, visible, and so on.
And that's what I was saying,
there's [INAUDIBLE] was
an [INAUDIBLE] because-
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, [LAUGH] of course,
I was making an emphasis
rhetorically [INAUDIBLE] our
attention but
I think you're right.
So can I just come back to that?
Cuz you're right, clearly.
That big data could be turned to
solve certain problems, which we
all want to solve in ways that
could be fully accountable and
useful, and
that would be wonderful.
I'm just saying we're not yet
at the position to have
the social architecture.
To deal with the possible
externalities of the data
collection and
the data processing,
that's the question I'm raising.
Those externalities
are fundamental and deep.
>> [INAUDIBLE] We're still
assuming that the subject of
the surveillance
is always humans.
>> No, sure.
>> Thinking more that there's
a lot of opaque entities
that maybe we could bring
a lot more surveillance.
>> Absolutely.
Again, I wasn't saying
surveillance of nonhuman
subjects or
other entities was a problem.
I was focusing on the human
problem because I think that's
where we start from,
but thank you.
Now then I better wrap a few
together and then try.
>> Thank you for a wonderful and
productive talk.
I was kindof struck by how,
until you had this exchange with
Glen, that the word privacy
wasn't too much in here.
Because it seems like a lot
of these social problems we
usually put in
the privacy bucket.
>> Yeah.
>> But there, and especially
after the Equifax hack,
when most Americans social
security numbers are now
public in some form.
It doesn't seem like people
get very upset about privacy,
so I thought there was
something very productive about
moving to the language
of freedom instead.
So could you talk a little bit
about the move from privacy to
freedom, what's driving that?
>> Yeah, I'll take a few
together on that, yeah.
>> It's actually
related to that.
It's a question
about comparison.
And in the first place, it was
interesting to me that you
mentioned it was useful
to compare big data and
older moment of
statistical expansion.
And you pointed out their
similarities and differences.
And you sort of wonder, okay,
why compared to that moment in
time and not to something else.
Because that moment in time,
okay, there's scale,
there's numbers.
There's not continuity, there's
not [INAUDIBLE] difference.
You might find other comparisons
that might giveyou those things
that are not there in stats,
so one comparison you might
do because you mentioned
fog is behaviorism.
People who are doing this kind
of like fog behavior design kind
of thing and I think what
[INAUDIBLE] is talking about
the critique or see for
a kind of behavior things.
It's not exactly the same
as behaviors and
the similarities and differences
again but it does bring me back
specifically to
the question of freedom.
It seems to me like it
wasn't clear to me why
continuous tracking actually
was a threat to autonomy.
I imagine that if you asked
a lot of people who advocate for
it now they'd say no,
no, no it's not
necessarily that at all.
It's [INAUDIBLE] power angle.
>> The link may be to the
autonomy comes via this sort of
like Skinner box
notion of the social.
>> And that might be a sort of
connection that you can have.
>> Okay,
these are great questions,
I'll take a few together, yeah?
>> I was thinking sort of
similar questions about.
So what's different now
that we have big data?
And what is this category in
relation to some of the ways
social knowledge was produced
before there was data and
still being produced now.
Because I'm thinking, well, you
said data is continuous and I
thought well, that's interesting
because actually it's not.
I mean that's what's funny about
data is you take a chunk here,
you take a chunk here and
it's not like life at all that
way and I say you know what's
another way to think
about social knowledge?
And that like live performance.
Things happening in the now and
I think a lot about music and
music is certainly a form
of social knowledge,
a way of understanding order,
of experiencing certain
tensions and collaborations.
And that goes on.
>> Yeah.
>> There are these forms
of knowledge that go on and
learn about the world and
it creates a sense of order.
And now you have big data, but
what the relationship
between the two?
Now is big data more important,
somehow than these other,
I was also thinking of gossip.
I mean gossip is exactly,
it's exposure of knowledge
that's supposed to be private.
It has this interesting
reverse power potential and
that still goes on today.
So that's why I'm with
you on the big data, but
I'm like what about all
the other stuff and
[INAUDIBLE] relation
between those two?
>> Yeah, great point.
Great point.
Shall I take those three and
then [CROSSTALK].
Yeah, that is a great,
let me see.
Privacy, yeah,
that's quite deliberate that
I didn't mention the privacy,
because there's no
clear resolution yet
about how we reconfigure
the concept of privacy.
To fit this massive
reconfiguration of social
knowledge, knowledge gathering,
and this is a big problem.
Judy Cowen has been
writing about it, and
Mary Hildebrandon,
Holland, and others.
Therefore, all those writers
are trying to get underneath
the concept of privilege
to something deeper
that might enable us
to reconfigure it.
Because old, if you're like 19th
century liberal privacy about
here's your garden and
no one can enter your garden.
That's just absurd.
They're already in your garden,
they are in your plants and
so on.
That's absurd.
So we have to have a totally
different thinking of what
privacy is and we need to dig
down to deeper values and
autonomy's one.
Pagel happens to
call it freedom but
he means what we
mean by autonomy.
Even though that word is
itself a bit problematic,
cuz the idea of
the law in there.
But when you get to how Hegel
describes it, he doesn't mean
the private, the liberal
individual subject at all.
He means something
radically different,
profoundly relational.
So that's why I
think it's helpful.
So yes, that's exactly
what they're trying to do.
From there,
we can move back to privacy.
And that's what
people like Cohen and
[INAUDIBLE] are trying to do.
The question of comparison,
that's great.
I mean I write about behaviorism
in another part of the book, so
that is interesting.
And another part of the argument
that I didn't give you,
you have a chance to fill
in in here, is whether.
There's been a long move
in the 20th century.
Which is very different from
the 19th century move-around
statistics, to thin out our
sense of the social subject,
quite radically.
Behaviorism was part of that.
Revive behaviours and
could be seen as part of that.
Some talk about big data or
like Chris Anderson's notorious
article The End of Theory
he's very emphatically about
thinning out the human subject.
And saying we just don't need to
know about any of that squishy
stuff.
Now, almost self
paradigm positions but
they're pretty influential.
And they were some people argue
that with the neuroeconomics and
that some versions of that there
are sudden tendencies now I'm
not gonna claim to
pronounce on neuroeconomics
cuz this is a complex area.
But some more of
that is in the book.
I just felt the biggest,
the largest comparison
we can make to get
a sense of where we are on
the social of the 19th century.
That is why I presented it for
you.
Now Ian's very
interesting point.
You're right about continuity.
I mean the continuity of
the collection in time.
But behind that is
a very complex question,
which is really interesting.
Which is the data to count
regularly across
space has to generate
continuities at the level of
calculation and comparison,
which are not there in the raw
stuff that is made into data.
Now that's a deep point
about what data does and
what it should do.
So, that means there are all
sorts of areas of life,
which don't really fit so
well into that.
Nancy writes about the use of
the marvelous aspects of
how a music claims to
be a musician is enhanced by
social networking profoundly.
I wished I had been
a musician today.
It's just a much better and
easier life to connect in
various ways,
extremely interesting.
However, I think
there is a real issue
about what can not be included
in this type of knowledge.
My co-writer has written about
the parano as he calls it.
The role of stuff that
lies around the node
that by definition can not be
put into data and therefore it's
literally not just invisible, it
simply isn't there for counting.
That's a really big question
about how the social is being
transformed.
And that then leads
to a point that
everything in
the end comes down.
And this is why we need
historical comparisons about
what can be said
about the social.
If the aspects of life
which we just are in, and
live unregistered in the general
narratives as they're available
to be told about social,
there's a certain dislocation.
Maybe a very important one,
there's always dislocation
to some degree but
that's I think an area
interesting and
that's where I'm working on
other aspects of the book, so
thanks for raising that.
But there were more questions so
I need to go faster.
Thank you.
>> Materiality of the data.
>> Yeah.
>> You didn't
mention archiving or
the permanence of the data
at all in your conversation.
>> Yeah.
>> And the reason I wanna ask
about that cuz one of the things
I think that's different
about the big data
today is that it
a fix on in time but
anyone person.
>> Yeah.
>> That seems to very much push
against the notion of autonomy,
that you can be many
people at one time.
But the fixedness
of data assumes
that you are only one
person at one time.
And that,
limits freedom autonomy.
Whatever we want to call it.
And so, can you say something
about immateriality?
>> Yeah, that's a great point.
Great point.
Okay, there was another one.
Did you have a topic?
>> Yeah
>> We'll try to take
one to two more.
>> Yeah.
The question I thought
I needed to ask was
you have a concern about the
ethics of data collection and
you sometimes talk about
private data collection and
private capacity of data
collection there is also
continued state collection,
there is also say something like
social scientific
academic chart.
So can I ask you are focusing
on the private one because
it's the most pressing or
do you think the problems
are universal?
But now I want to adjust
the question a little,
based on what Ian was asking
cuz that makes me think
maybe what you're interested in
is the institutional production
of social knowledge.
I mean there's a whole set of
questions about other forms of
social knowledge that aren't
always in the hands of,
they're in certain hands and
not others.
Like Microsoft is talking all
about democratizing AI but
I think they're just gonna
hold onto the mechanism for
doing it and democratize how you
get to pay for those results.
Right, so I'm still not in
a position where I can do
big data collection.
But I can produce music or
narrative.
And so
is it the pressure of this very
particular institutional forms
of production that's
coming in these places,
the kind of institutions
that can do it at scale.
And then it's available and not,
but it's also felt and not.
So I guess I'm more
interested in [CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah, that's a very
interesting question.
Just going back to
the previous one about memory.
I did mention in passing,
I was going, so
much to say in 30 minutes.
Yes, clearly that's
very important.
Which is that because data
is archived, it's stored
with a stamp as it were or
the particularity of the moment.
And could be reused again at
a later time maybe in a very
different context.
This creates all these
problems in contextual
integrity that have
in this [INAUDIBLE].
That's fundamental.
Now you could certainly argue.
That the result of that is to
interfere with the temporal
integrity of the self.
And that's another layer
of problem which I think is
important.
I mean everyone remembers,
I'm sure,
that truly gut-wrenching moment
when Facebook at the end of
the person's year sent to
a father who happened to be
a techie a picture of his
daughter, who died that year.
Say, any relations
with this person?
He wrote a wonderfully eloquent
blog called Algorithmic Cruelty.
Which was gut wrenching because
he understood exactly how
it had happened.
But they also felt pained
in the deepest possible,
this is absolutely wrong and yet
it is generated by
processes I understand.
So I think you're right when we
move on to the temporal side
they're even more issues about
the question of integrity I
think that for
me that reinforces the argument
unless you think we gradually
become used to this chapter.
I hope that we absolutely do not
become used to these changes and
that's sort of simple
crude example.
So I'm sure there's
more we can talk about.
But thank you for
raising the time question.
Carlton, that's a great point.
I'm using the word puppet
private here, simply to signal
a different assemblage
of knowledge, authority,
trust and so on, which is
therefore relatively crude and
it doesn't say map on to certain
types of institutions simply and
the state of course remains
profoundly interested in private
data collection.
And you may not know but
in Britain,
the British government
seriously debated about four or
five years ago until something
stopped it, it's not clear what.
Abandoning the national census,
about five years ago there was
a small debate about that.
On the basis that far better
data was being gathered
all the time by
private organizations.
The state was running
out of money.
Why not just defer that
fundamental faculty of the state
which is to know its
population in order to govern?
So I think there are very
interesting relations between
this stage in part, and
which raise massive
political theory questions.
But you're implying the question
which goes back to Glenn's,
which I think is
a really serious point.
Well, couldn't we imagine that
with a different assemblage,
a different configuration or
authority trust or so on, we
could consent to more data being
gathered about ourselves and
being stored.
I don't deny that for a moment.
That's why I pointedly
mentioned the health case.
But that will require very
different social architecture
for what we have in the moment.
I know that Glenn is
exactly interested in.
But I think I'm trying to point
out these extremely difficult
questions to generate such
a social architecture.
It's never been
done in the past.
It's only been done by states
which did not successfully
generate trust.
We don't barely know
how to solve that
higher dimensional
interdependence problem.
So I'm exposing the problem,
yes it will be great if we had
better solutions because we're
not gonna stop data collection.
And I would love it to be
put to more positive things.
But I think we're barely at
the beginning of even posing
the question let
alone solving it.
>> So thank you so
much for your talk.
I think what I'm struck by
[INAUDIBLE] having, just the day
to day conversations about
collecting data, it's less of
a n equal all, and more of
an n of everything I can get.
>> Yeah.
>> Precisely the interest in
getting what I can without
the possibility of
the disruption of
requesting consent,
because that might impinge on
either the representatives,
my sample, but
then this really odd disconnect.
I don't know if
it's a disconnect.
What do you make of
the willingness to say one,
I'll work with
what I can get and
I'm gonna extrapolate
out from there.
It's not as though
I've ever talked with
any engineer in this area
that said what we really need
is a sensor on every person,
every baby, every second.
None of them feel like
that's necessary,
precisely because they imagine
that What they're working on is
a new statistics to
extrapolate and project.
>> In fact, the people who say
that are the computational
scientists.
>> Absolutely.
>> Who have the vision
of what if everyone was.
>> Yeah, there's no engineer who
feels like that's necessary.
And I think it perhaps goes back
to diagnosis of A certain set of
assumptions about the natural
state of a human being.
>> Yeah.
>> So what do you make of
that thinking about the end?
>> Well, that's obviously
very encouraging,
in other words implicitly
there is resistance.
I'm not claiming any special,
there's a sort of
resistance here.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Resistance is unnecessary.
>> Yeah.
>> Well-
>> Well, I don't really need
a sensor on every baby,
I just need some babies.
>> Right, right.
>> The babies that
I could get to.
I mean, if you suggested-
>> Yeah, I mean-
>> It's like,
we could encourage,
we could refer them-
>> And that, of course,
is the older model of building
statistical knowledge,
which didn't raise this sort of
externality problem that I'm
talking about.
But I think the picture
looks rather differently if
you go study what our
marketers are talking about,
the gathering information.
Their business model is about
gathering all information at
all times, and hoping to use it.
For example, there's a
interesting report on the future
of wearables by Price Waterhouse
Cooper, came out three or
four years ago.
And Joe Thoreau talks about it
in his book on a shopping mall
and surveillance.
Which seriously, without
irony or humor suggested that
if everyone started to have
a wearable built in which
was continuously tracking
the state of their body and
continuously matched with
all the available marketing
information about what they
like and what they don't.
They could be told,
well you're sweaty now,
maybe you should get
a bottle of water.
But we know you like that
store around the corner, but
their offering a special
deal and so on.
In other words, what I'm trying
to get at is the core conception
which has some spurious basis in
certain stories about big data.
To be more explicit, this is not
a good science, it's a certain
story that Anderson has told,
and some very, very practical
fixes in the marketing world,
which are working to install
the possibility of n equals
all as a default setting.
McKinseys have written reports
arguing that we need that
default setting of assuming
the data would be collected,
that I think raises questions.
>> [INAUDIBLE] I heard
you say something,
please go ahead,
please go ahead.
>> It's just, I'm glad
you mentioned marketing.
So in the spaces that I study,
where this proposition of data
collection is always present.
It's very much embedded in
marketing and advertising.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> But it often still
feels as if, well,
there's two things
that I think of.
There's this fabulous
stuff on peak ads, right,
that we sort of have already hit
the moment where the promise of
advertising and
marketing is not.
There's a rhetoric of it,
a mythos of it but
it's not where
things really are.
And so the big data stuff is
participating in a rhetoric that
really needs to be revisited.
So I'm glad you mentioned the
marketing cuz I do wonder how we
make sense of these tensions
that sort of drag to
revive a marketing and
advertising model.
That actually has a lot of
empirical fragility to it,
that many people actually
in the space know?
>> Sure.
>> And
are a bit of
>> Well,
again you'll point into
the fact there are complex
cultural tensions being
worked out and that's good.
And that's as we would expect if
this was a social process, but
I can't deny.
I've been very struck by Joseph
Turow's account of the retail
marketing area.
Which doesn't see the type
of resistance and
drawback that you're
talking about.
It may be different
in different sectors.
So clearly, the picture
is still emerging and
I am trying to draw a journal
narrative out of this.
And say that if we were to
continue entirely in this
direction, there will be these
major, hence, my alarm bell.
But, I'm glad to hear that.
And music might be
a special case.
I don't know.
That's quite,
or the game industry might
be very interesting.
We should talk more about that,
yeah.
>> The big data step is trying
to animate something people know
is deeply crumbling
under their feet.
And so there is hope
that it [INAUDIBLE] it.
>> Right, got it.
>> An increasing realization.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Well we should talk more, and
I hope you are right.
But if you look, I've also being
doing the study of the big
discourse about big data
collection while economic from
the leading spokes organisations
for global business, and
then I'm making any
concessions at all and
their language about this.
And then their reports
have some weight and so
that's another one of my
sources behind the report.
But it's luckily
a complex picture,
more complex than I
painted to the questions.
Glenn, did you want to
come back and speak?
>> There's an important
distinction that was coming up
for describing between the way
in which data is used and
what data is collected.
>> Yeah.
>> And
both those seems to me different
threats when it comes to
autonomy.
>> Yeah
>> So
one mode is data
is collected and
simply the fact that it
gets surfaced in various
ways in social context
undermines my control.
Or my relationship to how I'm
perceived socially understood by
other people and what I'm
able to do on my own because
of how it would be
perceived by others.
That's sort of one
set of issues.
And that seems to raise issues
about you have to have humility
because otherwise you get
coerced to share things In
the ways that you
were describing.
There's another set of
issues where actually it's
the recommendations that
are coming back to me and
my willingness to accept those.
And the power of what's being
offered to me that's actually
the threat to autonomy.
>> Yes.
>> And the erosion of
the individual's real authority
over her own.
>> Yeah.
>> Choices.
And those seem to me actually to
be two somewhat separate things
which are both threatening
different aspects of autonomy and-
>> This is great.
Autonomy is once you
start to open it out and
rework with it from now.
It's a very complex concept, but
we need to fill it
in lots of new ways.
So I wouldn't disagree
with that for a moment.
I think they're actually
directly connected though
because Hagel's view and this
is why I find it so compelling.
Is that there never was a final
stability of the self it's
endlessly changing in mutual
relations with others.
While still trying to go
on making sense of itself.
So as you say,
the recommendations we receive
from others that we integrate
into our sense of ourselves
are really crucial to that.
Now I've been reading today and
discussing in another
reading group over in
tomorrow is the Karen Young
piece on the Hyper Nudge.
And anyway it's quite a new
piece by legal theorists at
King's College London taking
the simple liberal knowledge of
the nudge relatively
the innocent.
Why not encourage people to
by slightly more healthy or
whatever it might be by
placing things differently.
So which in itself is
not in any way offensive
to liberal principles,
although that has been debated.
With the hyper nudge
which is installing,
nudging at almost every point
in the million point space.
Every point the self
comes up against,
you can immediately see you
start to get the feedback that
looks like I'm talking about.
And her argument is that this is
in principle necessarily opaque
and therefore, it must interfere
that autonomy we thought
the subject had to frame
its choices about choices.
It's second all to choices.
They are the core, and
that is really interesting.
So I think the two
link together.
And that is why I just wanna
raise the question as to whether
continuous data collection as a
default on norm doesn't have and
the playbacks don't necessarily
come from that when we all
surveil each other as,
of course, we do.
I do as much as anyone, creates
externalities moral, ethical,
practical and also in terms
of social legitimacy for
the institutions we need for
markets and
other things which we
just have to think about.
So that’s, I raise the question.
>> Okay [INAUDIBLE] thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.